هل من الممكن أن تكون قد مررت بها
طوال هذا الوقت وكانت اختبارات سلبية كاذبة
ما يقوله طبيبك
وكيف يمكن أن يحدث هذا ،
فأنت تعلم أنه من الممكن بالتأكيد
في هذه المرحلة لا أحد يقول على وجه اليقين
ما حدث ولكنك تعلم  كان لدي الكثير
من الأعراض العصبية في
البداية ، كيف بدأت بالنسبة لي ،
انتهى بي الأمر في المستشفى للعلاج من
ديون بيريه ، ثم تعلمون انتهى بي
الأمر باختبارين سلبيين في الأسابيع التالية
بعد ذلك لا يزال لدي الكثير من
الأعراض العصبية ولكن  أخبروني
أن أتوقع ذلك لأنه ربما حتى شهور
، وعندما تقول أعراضًا غير منطقية ،
فماذا تعني على وجه التحديد الكثير من
الضعف وخدر عضلاتي ، مما يؤدي إلى
آلام إطلاق النار مثل آلام إطلاق النار الكهربائية
كل بضع ثوانٍ فقط تنطلق في
كل مكان من خلال الصداع النصفي الجسدي الذي
تعرفه  فقط أشعر بدوار
شديد ، كما أن معدل ضربات قلبي وضغط دمي
متوقف حقًا ولا يزال
مستمراً مثل 240 فوق 145 من ضغط الدم
عندما أعاني  r كان ضغط الدم متساويًا
ثم أيضًا معدل ضربات القلب ،
أجريت اختبار طاولة مائلة لدى طبيب القلب الخاص بي
وجعلوني أقف لمدة ثلاث
دقائق وبعد ثلاث دقائق كان معدل نبضات قلبي
204 ، لذا فهذه هي نوع
الجهاز العصبي مثل الجهاز العصبي
اللاإرادي  المشكلات التي تحدث لي
ولكن للمضي قدمًا في بداية
شهر يونيو ، بدأت أعاني من الكثير
من أعراض الجهاز الهضمي التي لم أكن
أتعرف عليها ، القيء ، والغثيان ، فأنت لا تعرف أي
شهية على الإطلاق مثل عدم الشعور
بالجوع بدون تناول الطعام و  لذلك ذهبت
وأجري الاختبار مرة أخرى وعادت
إيجابية جدًا ، لذلك يا إلهي ، قلبي
يخرج إليكم و د.  غاندر عندما
استمعنا إليها وخاصة الحديث
عن أعراضها المروعة لكل هذا
لكل ما تعرفه مرتين أو
مرتين مختلفتين لم أسمع بهذا من
قبل وأعتقد أنك
ستخرج Kovac مثل البطانة الفضية هي أنت
تنتهي  بالأجسام المضادة ونأمل
ألا تعتقد أنك لم تحصل عليها
لفترة طويلة ، كيف كان هذا ممكنًا
طبيًا جيدًا ، لقد رأينا هذا
في وقت مبكر من الوباء مع البيانات
الواردة من كوريا الجنوبية أن الناس كانت نتيجة
اختبارهم إيجابية على مدى فترة طويلة  فترة من
الزمن وأعتقد أن
الشيء الذي يجب التأكيد عليه هنا هو أننا لا
نعتقد أن هذا هو عدوى مرة أخرى لكثير من الناس ،
إنه نوع ما يشبه إذا كنت تعتقد أن
السارق يأتي في منزلك
ويترك بصمات أصابع في جميع أنحاء
منزلك ثم يغادرون قد
لا يزالون يجدونها  بصمات الأصابع على الرغم من
أن السارق لم يعد في
منزلك وهذا ما يحدث بشكل أساسي
مع اختبار الفيروس التاجي اختبار PCR
الذي يبحث عن المادة الوراثية
للفيروس الآن بعد أن أصبح sai  د
الاختبارات في النهاية ، كانت الأعراض التي
تعاني منها منفصلة إلى حد ما حتى تعرف
أن مشكلة الفيروس التاجي هي أنه
بمجرد اختفاء الفيروس ، فقد تسبب في
الكثير من الضرر حتى يمكن أن ينتهي الأمر بالناس مع
الالتهاب الرئوي الإضافي ، الالتهاب
الرئوي البكتيري ، إلخ.
نتيجة للضرر الذي
لحق برئتيهم ، فإن الطريقة الرئيسية التي يتسبب بها هذا
الفيروس في الإصابة بالمرض هي من خلال
نظام مناعي منظم ملتهب حقًا
يمكنه مهاجمة الجسم ، ومن ثم
يكون لديك أيضًا كجزء من
التهاب الأوعية الدموية ، وبالتالي فإن الأعراض
هي  أن تكون في الواقع
متسقة تمامًا مع ما قد
تتوقعه وشخص يعاني من مشاكل مستمرة ،
تعلمون أن مشاكل الجهاز المناعي
والأوعية الدموية جيدة وميشيل
أريد فقط أن أعطيك الكلمة الأخيرة السريعة
وبعد ذلك سأقول وداعا كما
تعلمون  إنه فصل الصيف ، هناك بعض
الأشخاص في أجزاء من البلاد رأينا
بعض الزيادة الطفيفة في الكثير من هذه
الحالات في ولايات معينة ويفكر الناس ،
أليس كذلك  شيء كبير
بعد الآن ، ماذا تريد أن تقول لهؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم ، أقول إنه ربما يكون
صعبًا إذا لم تكن تعاني منه أو
كنت لا تعرف أي شخص يمر به
، فقد يكون من السهل محاولة إبعاده
من عقلك ولكن عندما تكون في هذا
الموقف ، كنت في السرير لمدة
تسعة أسابيع تقريبًا ، لذا فقد انقلبت تمامًا في
حياتي وكذلك حياة عائلتي
، وأنت تعلم لا تأخذ الأمر على محمل الجد ، فهذا
ليس شيئًا أعتقد أن أي شخص
يعرف حقًا تمامًا كيف
سيؤثر ذلك على الأشخاص على المدى الطويل ، لذا فأنت تعلم أن
تعتني بنفسك وتعتني بالآخرين